THE GREGG GUTFELD SHOW IS NEXT.
>> I DIDN'T THINK WE GET TO THE
POINT WHERE YOU HAD PUTIN SAYING
IT'S AS INTENSE AS IT WAS IS THE
80s.
I HEARD IT CALLED A HOT PIECE.
>> THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO DESCRIBE
IT.
>> YES, HOT PIECE.
YOU HAVE TO LOVE DANA.
[APPLAUSE]
HOLLYWOOD IS SHAKING IN THEIR
REBOOTS.
ROSEANN'S NEW DEBUT HAD OVER
80 MILLION VIEWERS.
ALMOST TWICE THE SHOW.
[LAUGHTER]
GUESS WHERE ROSEANN SCORED THE
HIGHEST?
TULSA, OKLAHOMA.
THAT IS LITERALLY THE MIDDLE OF
AMERICA.
THINK ABOUT IT.
IF TV WERE ARCHERY
IF TV WERE ARCHERY ROSEANN HIT
THE BULL'S-EYE.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT JOBS, JACKIE.
HE SAID HE WOULD SHAKE THINGS
UP.
>> HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THE NEWS
NOW THINGS ARE WORSE.
>> [INAUDIBLE] THE REAL NEWS.
>> SEE WHAT I MEAN?
>> GREG: THE ROSEANN IS A TRUMP
IN THE SISTER IS A RESISTOR.
THE SHOW DID NOT ALIENATE HALF
THE COUNTRY WHICH IS MAYBE WHITE
SCORED BIG.
WE ALL HAVE THE FAMILY MEMBER WE
WOULD RATHER NOT TALK TO WHEN
THE DISCUSSION TURNS TO
POLITICS.
MINE IS IN A CAGE I BUILT OUT OF
REC ROOM BONES.
IN ROSEANN'S HOUSE SHE HAS DONE
SOME VERY, VERY STRANGE THINGS
IN HER PAST.
MAYBE SHE'S TRYING TO MAKE UP
FOR BY CREATING A SHOWED TO PULL
PEOPLE TOGETHER RATHER THAN
APART.
COMING OUT IS PRO- TRUMP IN
HOLLYWOOD IS LIKE COMING OUT
LIKE A FISH IN A BEAR SANCTUARY.
THAT WASN'T THE ONLY REALLY DO.
CONSIDER CNN HE SAID -- OH STOP
IT -- THEY SAID ENOUGH WITH
FOREIGN-POLICY IN IT AND
NATIONAL DEFENSE, WE WANT TO
MAKE OVER.
WE ARE NOW THE NEW WEATHER
CHANNEL, ALL STORMY, ALL THE
TIME.
[APPLAUSE]
MUCH LIKE ROSEANNE, THIS REBOOT
HINGES ON ONE WOMAN.
I DON'T BLAME CNN.
WHEN THINGS ARE TOUGH YOU HAVE
TO GO WITH WHAT THEY KNOW AND
THEY KNOW STORMY THE BACK IN
FRONT OF THEIR HAND.
BUT CNN, AT LEAST BE HONEST
ABOUT IT.
WHEN YOUR NEWS HAS GONE FROM
HARD TO SEMI- HARD, THAT REBATE
NEEDS A REBRAND.
LUCKILY WE GOT A SNEAK PEEK.
IT'S GREAT.
>> ARE YOU READY FOR THE MOST
INFORMATIVE NEWS PROGRAMS ON
CABLE?
YOU WILL LOVE THE NEW PRIMETIME
LINEUP.
AT EIGHT, IT'S BREAKING NEWS
HOUR.
>> WAS STORMY DANIELS.
>> DON'T MISS THE MARKET REPORT.
>> OR MAYBE YOU'RE HUNGRY FOR
THE LATEST ON CAPITOL HILL.
AT TEN GET INFORMATION.
>> AND FOR YOU NIGHT OWLS YOU
CAN GET -- WITH JAKE TAPPER.
IT'S A NEW PRIMETIME LINEUP.
>> THE HOTTEST CHANNEL.
>> HAD WATCHED.
EVERY MINUTE OF IT.
OF COURSE THAT IS NOT ALL CNN
COVERS, JUST FEELS THAT WAY.
WE COVERED REBOOTS THAT WORK AND
REBOOTS THAT DON'T, LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS INCAPABLE OF
REBOOTING.
>> I WAS REALLY STRUCK BY HOW
PEOPLE SAID THAT TO ME, MOSTLY
PEOPLE AND THE PRESS.
FOR WHATEVER REASON LIKE GO AWAY
FOR WHATEVER REASON LIKE GO AWA
AWAY.
I HAD A YOUNG PERSON WORK FOR ME
GO BACK INTO RESEARCH, THEY
NEVER SAID THAT TO ANY MAN WHO
IS NOT ELECTED.
>> GREG: BECAUSE NONE OF THEM
CALLED THE STATE BACKWARDS FOR
VOTING FOR THE OTHER GUY.
HILLARY JUST CAN'T REBOOT.
LIKE WHEN YOU GET AN AIR MESSAGE
ON YOUR COMPUTER AND YOU SHUT IT
DOWN ANY THINK IT'LL BE GONE SEE
POWER IT UP, BUT IT'S STILL
THERE.
HILLARY, YOU CAN'T REBOOT HER OR
BOOT HER.
THE CHALLENGE IS, WHAT YOU DO IN
THE COUNTRY IS BACK ON ITS FEET
AND YOU STILL WANT TO REPORT THE
BAD STUFF?
YOU NEED PEOPLE WHO WILL SAY
WHAT THEY WANT TO SAY EVEN WHEN
THEY DON'T MEAN IT.
YOU NEED MORE THAN A REBOOT, YOU
NEED A ROBOT.
>> HIS HESITATION TO SAY
ANYTHING IS JUST INSANE.
>> TO FIND YOUR FAVORITE ANTI-
TRUMP TALKING HEADS WINDED AND
BORING?
OUR HIGHLY TRAINED SCIENTIST HAS
ALL THIS WITH QUALITY ASSURANCE.
IT SIMPLIFIED RHETORIC THAT
CALLS FOR 45'S IMPEACHMENT.
>> TRUMP COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA.
HE IS A CLUMSY -- HE OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE.
>> HE IS NOT MENTALLY UNFIT, HE
IS PHYSICALLY UNFIT.
HE IS AN ADULT OR.
>> EVERYBODY KNEW ABOUT THAT
ONE.
>> LET EVERY CABLE TV SHOW THAT
ONCE AN ANTI- TRUMP 3000 CAN
HAVE ONE.
>> THEY HAVE GRANDFATHER HARD OF
HEARING MODE.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS VERY BAD.
HE IS VERY BAD.
>> SO ORDER YOURS TODAY.
>> VERY BAD.
VERY BAD.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: WELL DONE.
ALL THE STUFF THE MEDIA KEEPS
THROWING AT US, COLLUSION,
DEMENTIA, HIS FAMILY AND DIET,
IT'S MY COMPUTING.
WHAT'S NECESSARY IS A TOTAL
REBOOT OF THE HEART, IF ONLY
THEY HAD ONE.
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST.
HE HAS MORE SENSE THAN THE KIDS
PIGGY BANK.
CANDACE OWEN.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: HE'S PRODUCE MORE HITS
THAN SNOW DOG.
ROB LAW.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: HE ONCE CALLED ANIMAL
CONTROL AND THE EASTER BUNNY.
NATIONAL REVIEW REPORTER CAT.
AND FINALLY HIS DINNER PLATE CAN
PICK UP ALL THE MAJOR-LEAGUE
BASEBALL CHANNELS.
TYRUS.
[APPLAUSE]
WHAT YOU TAKE OF THE CNN
COVERAGE SO FAR OF STORMY
DANIELS?
IS IT PERTINENT OR JUST
PERNICIOUS?
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW IT'S A
NEW PLATFORM.
WHEN HE SHOWED IS ACCURATE.
SHE IS RUNNING THE CNN NETWORK
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SHE'S GONE QUITE THE RAISE AND
PROMOTION.
>> GOOD FOR HER.
>> COULD SHE BE IN THE ARE OF
THE WOMAN, 2020 RUNNING FOR
OFFICE?
>> SHOULD HAVE A BETTER CHANCE
THAN HILLARY CLINTON DID.
>> GREG: I THINK BILL WOULD LIKE
THAT THEY SHOULD RUN TOGETHER.
POOR BILL.
ROB, YOUR FILM PRODUCER OR SO
YOU TELL PEOPLE.
YOU ARE DOING CHEERS AND KEVIN
CAN WAIT, THERE'S ONE IN BETWEEN
HOW IS HOLLYWOOD TAKING THIS
ROSEANNE RESURGENT'S?
ARE THEY LEARNING ANYTHING?
>> HOLLYWOOD IS THE PLACE YOU
LEARNED THE WRONG LESSON ALL THE
TIME.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE CELEBRATING.
IT'S A GIGANTIC AUDIENCE RIGHT
NOW SHE BROUGHT THE SITCOM BACK
AND GAVE ABC HUGE LIFT.
BUT THEY'RE LOOKING AROUND FOR
MORE COMEDIES THAT ARE RELEVANT.
IT'S WRONG TO DECIDE THAT WHAT
MADE ROSEANNE POPULAR IS THAT
SHE'S PRO- TRUMP.
THE SHOW ITSELF IS MIXED AND
BALANCE.
BUT IT'S RELEVANT.
AND IT'S FUNNY, IT'S NOT
QUIRKIER HIPPER CLEVER JUST
FUNNY.
SHE'S A FUNNY PERSON.
SHE AND HER SISTER ARGUE IN A
FUNNY WAY.
IT'S WHAT EVERYBODY WANTS IN A
HALF-HOUR COMEDY.
>> IT DOES REMIND ME A BIT OF
ALL IN THE FAMILY.
THAT MAKES ROSEANNE ARCHIE.
>> ALL IN THE FAMILY WAS
DESIGNED TO BE A SHOW WHERE
ARCHIE LEARNED A LESSON ABOUT
THE PROGRESS OF MODERN POLITICS.
INSTEAD EVERYONE WHO WATCHED THE
SHOW WAS LIKE ARCHIE'S A HERO.
HE BOUGHT THE HOUSE IN WORLD WAR
II AND THESE CAN LOOK LIKE AN
ABSURD HIPPIE.
ARCHIE WAS A HERO.
WHEN HE IS WATCHING HE REALIZED
HE DID IT WRONG.
>> THE VILLAIN BECAME THE HERO.
DO YOU THINK THE SHOW WILL HEAL
US OR DO YOU THINK HILLARY WILL
DIVIDE US?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I HATE MOST
THINGS, BUT I CANNOT HATE
ROSEANNE.
I LOVED IT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY GOOD.
AS FOR HILLARY, WHINING ABOUT
THE SEXISM THING AND SAY NOBODY
EVER TOLD THE MAN TO GO AWAY, I
DON'T THINK I'VE EVER SEEN
ANYBODY, MALE OR FEMALE CONTINUE
TO HAVE NOTHING TO SAY BUT STILL
BE UP THERE SAME THINGS.
[APPLAUSE]
IS JUST A SEXISM THING FOR THIS
REASON I LOST IS NOT MY FAULT,
THOSE ARE THINGS YOU TELL A
THERAPIST NOT A TV CAMERA.
>> ALSO IT'S NOT TRUE.
THEY SAY THAT EVERY CANDIDATE.
THEY SAID IT TO MITT ROMNEY THEY
SET IT TO MICHAEL DUKAKIS,
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY TO THE
LOSER.
>> GREG: TYRUS, GIVE ME YOUR
DEEPEST THOUGHTS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NO, I AM GOING TO GET IN
TROUBLE.